o solo estava agora que almoçar e vinha
quem está lá embaixo da roupa né eu me a
montanha está lá embaixo da bola e eu
vou aproveitar o começo muito rápido só
vem agora seguido do bora amiga uma
maneira de jogar ao meu melhor e ajudar
o grupo para o ronaldo
a europa está a fazer uma quebra nozes
eo este game agora é sério ninguém uma
guerra falava com isso aí ela pode usar
boné miguel monteiro
só que eu não sei quem foi que o jogo
nem um goleiro profissional me escalarem
fits pneus não somente para a nova moda
[Aplausos]
olha isso aí é fazer da fpf né perguntou
o que estava a família não tem porque eu
não ter conseguido escapar à área do
pedido de cpi
não quero nem falar de coisas me corram
thayla 1 milhão no tempo
leonan enquanto estás miguel monteiro
com 414 fw miguel aidar miguel olha o
número 1 milhão
desculpa melhor desculpa desculpa eu
[Aplausos]
acho bem porque assim todo mundo vai
falar à mídia não ter lançado que são
funções nela eu vou mostrar que aquela
expulsão de muita ajuda mas estamos
abrindo portanto isto e já está perto
vai embora
perguntei-lhe ou então previsto o jogo
mas o garoto já monteiro
esta primeira estar lá o evento e sempre
trabalhou para devassar da equipe
miguel monteiro buscas hoje ontem não
fazia não tem culpa
o saco de luxo
então como evitar o choro da onça não
pode ser miguel voltei melhor esta não
não me faça perder em casa
agora miguel monteiro
vocês viram edições miguel visualizações
e likes de dinheiro e estudar já está na
casa de miguel monteiro monteiro
eu não sei miguel monteiro a 12 de
outubro
[Aplausos]
lá pude sair na janela já falei com o
chefe de equipa da yamaha ainda estava
lá pequena nahla apetite não buscar a
bola e virou vidrada vacilaram quanto
para escrevam shuai que eu mereço